[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport le rendez vous qu'il ne
faut absolument pas manquer si vous êtes
un amoureux du sport local aujourd'hui
l'émission sera entièrement dédiée au
handball et plus précisément au club
paris 92 dont tv 68 et partenaires nous
avons la chance de recevoir quatre
joueuses sur ce plateau et notre
consultant local présentation en musique
on commence à ma droite musique à l'art
26 ans nous vient tout droit du sud de
la france a été en sport études à
marseille a été formé à nice a donc un
caractère bien trempé côté palmarès à la
notamment terminé deuxième des jeux
olympiques avec l'équipe de france
la capitaine du paris 92 chloé bulleux
nous fait l'honneur de venir sur ce
plateau
bonjour bonjour quand allez-vous ça a
très bien merci vous êtes prête pour
l'émission vous avez un petit peu
réviser ou pas maintenant on verra sur
place au feeling on passe de l'autre
côté un musicale annie juste 20 ans et
la kilienne mvp du handball féminin ne
vous vous laissez pas avoir
son un sourire c'est à une redoutable
joueuse qui évolue au poste d'ailier
gauche parisienne alice mazens nous fait
le plaisir d'être sur ce plateau
bonjour comment ça va bien ça ça vous
première voix si voix la comparaison est
toujours mille toujours fait
on repasse de l'autre côté un musique
c'est la benjamine de cette émission
elle mesure 1 m 74 aime bien tout droit
de palaiseau elle est aussi rapide que
chef bold et en plus de cela allait un
très sympathique à jouer au poste
d'arrière demi centre paris 92
deborah la source sera avec nous pendant
une heure bonjour
quant à lui ça va très bien parce que
vous êtes prête à des missions traite
les jeunes bolt bages contentant moi
aussi d'être préparé accueilli comme ça
je prends moi je suis con par un
morcellement de personnalités qui
correspondent à votre personnalité aux
faces avant gauche musique elle est de
retour chez elle elle va faire des
étincelles j'en suis sûr à l'arrêter ses
premiers ballons au club de montigny le
bretonneux
aujourd'hui elle joue en première
division mais elle n'oublie pas d'où
elle vient
la gardienne du paris 92 victoria alric
est de retour chez elle pour une heure
devait passer chez les amis avant de
venir sur les linéaires packard hp le
temps pas encore après tout si vous fini
qu'est ce que ça vous fait et c'est
sympa c'est quick
c est familier c'est plutôt plaisant
parfait on termine à ma droite musique
c'est le vétéran sur ceux à plateaux ou
plutôt la voie de la sagesse l'a marqué
l'histoire des yvelines et de montigny
le bretonneux il en a été le président
de 1989 à 2006 il est à l'origine des
matchs organisés par le paris 92 au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
bonjour patrick cherbourg caen joue très
bien mais alors je suis ni mbappé
dilissen bolt en fait j'étais un peu le
didier deschamps du coup aujourd'hui non
pas du tout ça vous inspire pas non
servir à jeu presque les vomir alors
nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons donc parler exclusivement d'en
bas les yvelines sont elles une terre de
handball nous tenterons de répondre à la
question font également un focus sur le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines peut-il
devenir un jour le terrain officiel du
paris 92 mais avant de développer à ces
thèmes on va parler était résultat du
pari 92 justement
on commence donc par une première
thématique sur le début de saison du
paris 92 l'équipe est actuellement à la
5e place du championnat après seulement
à dix journée avec un bilan de six
victoires et quatre défaites et se
retrouve distancé au classement par des
équipes comme mais ce qui compte 30
points et brest à aix et à 29 points
mais paris 92 n'est qu'à cinq points du
podium la question sur ce thème
le club peut-il terminé sur le podium du
championnat de france cette année
oui ou non vous votez voilà avec la
petite raquette vers vers vers patrick
chabert ce que vous allez vous faire des
amis
je soutiens les contres alors chloé bout
vous avez votre raquette tout de suite
pour pour voter pourquoi oui parce que
je pense qu'on est capable vraiment on a
en fait on a plutôt gagné huit matches
et perdu deux c'est juste qu'on a perdu
deux matchs sur le tapis vert
mais bon les matches on les a joués les
à gagner donc je pense que c'est
possible qu'on fasse la même chose au
match retour en tout cas j'espère et si
c'est le cas on peut finir sur le podium
alice vous aussi vous avez vous été pour
oui moi j'ai voté pour bas comme chloé
je pense que on a su ils assurent toute
la première partie de saison
mettez ingrédients pour gagner tous les
matches on en a perdu 2 contre les deux
premières tout cas moi la cote
sportivement on va dire donc ouais on a
toutes nos chances
c'est pourquoi sa défaite sur tapis vert
et c'est un problème de ça et c'est
juste un problème de comme on dit
ministre administratif pardon voilà il
ya eu une erreur administrative et les
règles de la fédération de la lfh ou je
ne sais pas d'où mais n'étaient pas très
claires et du coup on s'est un peu fait
avoir et on a fait jouer une joueuse qui
n'auraient pas être qui n'est pas
qualifié qui n'aurait pas dû jouer sur
deux matches et du coup on a perdu on a
perdu ses points
alors je sais pas si on peut encore
faire appel
je sais pas si un dernier rappel en
cours ou pas mais oui voilà actuellement
on est cinquième au lieu-dit le match
est perdu en tout cas les deux matches
sont perdus patrick chabot vous qui êtes
un petit peu extérieur au club
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de cette
équipe de paris 92 cents soit ya quatre
filles qui vous regarde je fais
attention ce que je demandais si
l'équipe phare de de l'île de france
l'équipe phare professionnels de l'île
de france
donc je trouve ça très bien et puis
c'est quand même la référence donc c'est
toujours plaisant de venir voir les pour
des fois il ya des matches qui sont un
peu plus difficiles que d'autres pays
elle est super match quand même donc
puisque devoir c'est bien de voir des
jeunes comme ça qui arrive à passer à ce
bon niveau
victorien quand on regarde les résultats
n'y a eu finalement qu'une seule
victoire face aux membres du top 6
c'était contre nantes
comment comment l'expliquez vous bah on
va dire que c'est la même raison que la
raison précédente
sportivement il n'y a pas eu que cette
victoire après maintenant sur le papier
c'est noté qu'une victoire à nous de
trouver sur la face au retour que ce
sera le cas que le papier n'a pas raison
des braquets ce qui fait finalement
cancale et peut-être un petit peu face à
des grosses équipes cette saison
il est notamment voilà cette défaite
contre brest le 5 septembre dernier 36 à
25 encore face à metz à 30,5 à 24 grands
l'expliquez vous déjà on est une équipe
assez jeune ça fait un an un an et demi
qu'on travaille tout ensemble du coup il
n'ya pas encore tous les automatismes et
on n'est qu'au début de la saison donc
face à des grosses écuries comme metz et
brest qui sont déjà rodés qui ont dû
prendre sur le papier c'est forcément
difficile de rivaliser dès le début de
la saison après on travaille pour et
puis on verra comment on aura avancé
justement à lors des matches retour
c'était compliqué a encaissé ses
défaites contre
mais ce contre contre brest non faut
savoir que brest saison plus de trois
fois même quatre fois notre budget on
joue pas là on n'est pas censé jouer
dans le côlon dans la même cour que
clairement brest c'est avec les filles
qu'ils ont cru t il sur le sens ils sont
censés aller très loin en ligue des
champions voilà nous on est on reste
modeste voilà on se bat avec nos armes
on a fait de super résultat et c'était
pas dur à encaisser de perdre contre
brest qui est sans fin voilà si on avait
gagné ça aurait été fantastique ce
serait limite un miracle d'avoir perdu
c'est voilà c'est brest quoi brest elles
ont les meilleures joueuses du monde
émincez les championnes de france a donc
polluer pas faire mieux
ça reste du sport bien sûr qu'on peut
gagner sur un match mais met clairement
on est là où
on doit être quoi patrick chabot comment
on fait pour rebondir justement qu'on
perde autant face à des gros équipe pour
jouer
est ce que finalement on s'en fiche on
passe à autre chose ou est ce que au
contraire on est un petit peu dans le
dur renfermant les matchs les gros
matches les gros malgré sa façon comme
tu le disais vous aviez tout a tout à
gagner dans ce genre de match donc c'est
vrai qu'il faut je reprendre un peu la
philosophie l'arno pour le match bon ça
à nos pieds au trailer qui est
l'entraîneur peut pas être gagnée bon
maintenant il faut passer à autre chose
assez il se souvenait pas forcément les
matches qu'on a noté voilà qu'on a noté
dans le calendrier quoi c'est du positif
si on gagne mais il ya des matches
beaucoup plus important à gagner comme
comme besançon nantes nice
voilà des équipes des gros matches mais
des équipes peu plus à plus à notre
niveau je suis sûr en direct voilà quand
langues
par contre pour deux équipes un peu plus
faible par contre ça va on peut dire is
ça va non on va pas mais c'est toujours
des matches compliqués à prendre quand
les plus petites équipes on va dire mais
mais
ouais ça va on s'est bien débrouillé on
va dire pour se rendre tous les matches
faciles mais comme j'ai justement
victoria ses matchs contre ces petites
équipes il faut assumer un statut qu'il
n'y a pas de petites équipes on est un
des meilleurs championnats du monde
y a pas de petites équipes vraiment
victoria même s'il n'ya pas de petites
équipes
comment on fait pour yannick autre
résident qui sont derrière au classement
par pareil on s'échauffe pareil on
al'envie pareil on reste ensemble
jusqu'au bout
voilà pas faire l'erreur j'ai justement
dire que c'est des petites équipes parce
que ce n'est pas le cas et continuer
c'est finalement peut-être l'expérience
quand même qu'ils jouent deborah du coup
sûr le début de saison du paris 92 comme
vous disiez tout à l'heure
brest et metz sont des équipes qui se
connaissent très bien vous on voit
autour de cette table vous êtes assez
jeune notamment vous déborah
c'est aussi ça peut-être qu'il fait qui
fait que vous êtes un petit peu derrière
en ce moment bah peut-être après il n'y
a pas que ça parce que il ya plein de
facteurs qui rentrent en jeu dans un
match mais pourrait peut-être expérience
peut-être chloé irène
il ne faisait plus est sur le terrain
finalement à moi ya pas que ça mais vous
avez 26 ans 27 dans quelques jours ouais
non il ya c'est vrai qu'on m'a dit y'a
pas que ça il ya plein de choses qui
rentrent en jeu mais mais c'est vrai que
ça fait forcément ça joue un petit peu
on est une équipe jeune voilà une équipe
qui qui découvre aussi
donc oui quand on joue contre une équipe
comme brest ou les trois quarts des
joueuses ont déjà sur l'international on
doit jouer des compétitions des
championnats du monde de jouer la ligue
des champions bien sûr c'est c'est et ça
joue un petit peu sur l'enchaînement des
matches dirais pas sur un match comme ça
mais sur l'enchaînement sur toute une
saison
ça peut ça peut jouer vous jouez
également coupe d'europe il fait il faut
le rappeler la coupe uefa avec de longs
déplacements
généralement est-ce que ça fatigue aussi
les organismes finalement cloué cette
coupe d'europe
vous étiez au danemark il ya quelques
jours est ce que c'est ce que ça vous
fatiguez sa fatigue surtout que non là
cette année c'est un peu l'hécatombe
dans l'équipe on n'est pas beaucoup donc
voilà on obligeait un peu tiré sur les
mêmes et tout ça est bon par contre
c'est tellement on est tellement
chanceuse est tellement agréable de
jouer des matches comme ça que c'est pas
grave on se reposera plus tard lundi
soit d'accord c'est assez fatigant
après voilà
le planning est fait en sorte que l'on
puisse aussi avoir des temps de récup
pour pouvoir être justement comme chez
chloé vu qu'on n'est pas nombreuses mais
on nous exploite pas on a nos temps de
repos bien comme il faut pour pour être
présente sur t1 quoi on actuellement au
mot novembre rassurez-nous victoria où
enfin toute l'équipe n'est pas cramé on
est d'accord novembre non mais je pense
que la pause fera du bien à tout le
monde
là il nous reste un match après on a une
grosse coupure on va travailler le
handball travail et l'individuel travail
physique mais je pense qu'elle est
attendu partout
patricia baisse qui a un manque de
profondeur de banc peut-être paris iv je
dirais par malheureusement par
obligation donc c'est un peu embêtant
parce qu'il ya effectivement il ya un
hacker blessés aussi depuis pas mal de
temps donc ça en fait au moins 2 avec
tamara bon c'est un peu embêtant et puis
effectivement le fait de jouer tous les
trois jours à peu près donc
les filles ont pas tous le temps de
récupérer et parvenez serment de travail
et les les phases de jeu donc c'est
forcément fatigue en quoi la question il
quand vous pensez que paris 92 sera
champion de france alors le club a été
de nombreuses fois champion de vice
champion de france
oui mais jamais champion de france
depuis sa création en 1999
je pense que comme disait chloé s'est il
ya un problème de budget budget du club
donc c'est vrai qu'il est difficile de
rivaliser avec des équipes telles que
baisse effectivement brest surtout cette
année ils se sont considérablement
renforcées donc bah ça passait
s'essaieront je prends mon avis par par
des moyens financiers supplémentaires
et puis puis après le club fait son
travail comme il doit le faire je
faisais playoffs c'est à dire que fort
même ça c'est pas une équipe comme nous
c'est une bonne formule
il suffit pas d'être bon toute la saison
il suffit il suffit une fois qu'on est
qualifié en playoffs on sait jamais ce
qui peut se passer et je vous êtes assez
armés pour les pour les playoffs à votre
avis aujourd'hui peut-être pas dans un
mois et demi peut-être ça va dépendre
on va passer maintenant notre rubrique
focus
dans notre rubrique focus nous allons
aborder la question du centre de
formation par et 92 a dans ses rangs
quelques joueuses de la région
parisienne et notamment en vous victoria
amérique qui est originaire de montigny
le bretonneux
on le disait précédemment vous n'êtes
plus qu'à une trentaine de minutes du
palais des sports robert chantier d'un
terrain d'entraînement
voilà vous êtes juste à côté on peut le
dire de montigny-le-bretonneux également
vous du coup déborah et alice vous êtes
également la région parisienne
la question sur ce thème le par à 92
doit-il s'appuyer exclusivement sur des
joueuses de la région
la journée de france mission oui ou non
ou était exclusivement attention non non
non partagez vous faites
non parce que tout simplement pourquoi
alors allez tout simplement parce qu' il
peut y avoir effectivement des profils
intéressants sur la région parisienne
mais le recrutement passe aussi par des
des certaine solidité et enfin par des
joueuses expérience donc c'est un
heureux compromis je pense à une
diversité il faut la diversité vous êtes
la seule du cookie je n'ai pas de france
d'ailleurs je suis bien content que
c'est pour ça que vous avez voté hier je
me serais partie du plateau
non non c'est pas pour ça pas du tout
c'est jusqu'à 20 pour avoir une bonne
équipe une équipe une équipe
homogène l'équipe homogène voilà il faut
de la diversité il faut il faut que des
joueuses qui viennent de partout de tout
âge de tout niveau 2 enfin plutôt bonne
et qu'il y ait eu dit d'accord on est en
tant que jeune on revient presque tout
petit peu france vous êtes 7 jours / 14
issu le réseau actuellement donc mon
vient tout du même pôle pôle espoir en
tout cas pour le club c'est comme ça et
après ce qui change c'est plutôt des
joueuses professionnelles qui sont
recrutés à l'extérieur mais mais voilà
c'est bien on est bien équilibré ça fait
un peu moitié moitié
donc on a les deux et deux facettes way
de du doyen bonne chose pour vous êtes
d'accord avec avec alice ouais ouais
faut inventer de tous puisque la douce
sur 14 50 50 du coût pour vous recevoir
je sais pas si un chiffre à brac du bon
côté j'ai carrément du bon côté c'est
parfait mais je pensais pas que je pense
pas qu'ils aient un chiffre à avoir je
pense que c'est en fonction de déjouer
ce qui se présentait à des opportunités
qui se présentent à l'heure actuelle on
est moitié moitié et pourquoi pas
peut-être que l'année prochaine sera à
25,75 seul club en france d'ailleurs oui
à la moitié de l'équipe qui vient de la
région cultive toi ça me serait
dangereux de n'avoir que des jeunes
d'abord parce qu'il tiendrait pas la
distance et puis en même temps si les
places étaient prises par des étrangers
comme ça se passe un peu pour le foot il
ya des voyeurs feu philippe bana le
disait le directeur technique national
il faut laisser de la place aux jeunes
sinon les jeunes à terme ne vont peu
plus percée disent qu'on est de la place
parce qu'on n'a pas d'argent mais ce
qu'on était là parce que sa forte sont
fortes
usain bolt et qui tire d'ailleurs est-ce
que ça permet de créer une identité
aussi peut-être d'avoir des joueuses
d'île de france
je pense que oui parce que les clubs
peuvent se se reconnaître un petit peu
dans le dans cette équipe je vous prends
l'exemple victoria alors elle a passé
que deux saisons à montigny en moins de
15 et moins de 17 ans n'a jamais imaginé
qu'elle soit en une équipe
professionnelle et ça fait plaisir
moi j'avais la meilleure fin de saison
mais flanqué de 18 donc c'est bien de là
dollar en or vous identifier un petit
peu en étant de monter vos tenues à
victoria quand vous la voyez sur lequel
d'ailleurs comme pour d'autres ça fait
plaisir de voir il ya pas beaucoup les
supporters c'est ce qu'ils demandent
peut-être aussi chloé à avoir des
joueuses issues du cru ou pas je ne sais
rien je vais jamais discuté avec eux oui
je pense pas comme jean c'est un bon mix
les parisiennes voilà des choses qui
viennent d'ailleurs
c'est aussi sympa pour nous de jouer
avec des joueuses qui viennent de
république tchèque de roumanie
i2 de norvège pour nous c'est optent de
surtout pour nous jeunes sortons du pôle
du lycée va on a tout anti rom un temps
donc on s'attendait pas forcément à
jouer avec de jouer avec des joueuses
internationales étrangères donc c'est
bien ça fait un mélange de cultures et
puis oui c'est cool est-ce que c'est
compliqué aussi enfin vous disais il ya
des autrichiennes des norvégiennes
est-ce que c'est compliqué aussi
peut-être de l'est de les intégrer aussi
dans cette équipe
ou pas non parce que du coup ils
représentent la moitié de l'équipe donc
non pas du tout alors pas du tout non
moi je pense pas justement c'est top
c'est top d'avoir des choses comme ça
voilà de portage et de culture mont
progresse en anglais elle a progressé en
france et en échange on n'a pas vécu les
musées show biz du coup je vous passerai
des amis un peu partout en europe on
s'en remet à des pinasseyres des
pied-à-terre ap paris truqués
allez-y vous êtes d'accord avec avec toi
bah oui c'est toujours d'accord à
capitaux publics
et oui moi je suis d'accord comment fait
pour les intégrer du coup quand on est
sept joueuses de la région ile de france
ça se fait assez naturellement parce que
on est une équipe donc on est je vais
dire obligé ça fait un peu couteau sous
la gorge mais voilà c'est comme ça c'est
notre métier et on sait qu'on va devoir
travailler avec ses fils a pendant une
deux trois saisons donc donc tout le
monde à terre tout le monde et n'y a pas
de souci la barrière de la langue sur le
terror secouent leur santé au début
enfin personnellement tout cas après
chez que maintenant je me suis un peu
plus libéré que même s'il mon anglais
n'est pas parfait elle essaie de faire
des efforts et de me comprendre
donc ça va donc alice est d'accord avec
loic lorsque l'on est d'accord avec
alice mais c'est pas vrai son anglais
parfait sur les parcs est ce que j
essaye de faire monter des joueuses vers
cette équipe de paris 4 au 12
en fait cela devrait être le cas parce
qu'en fait tout joueuses à profil et
celle de les orienter
elles sont un club comme le nôtre c'est
un club qu'il de niveau moyen en
championnat de france
ça fait près de 17 et 20 ans 21 ans et
donc
on n'est qu'un club formateur c'est tout
et donc tout comme licite paris 92 est
aussi quelque part vous faut s'habituer
c'est vous saviez pas est devenu paris 4
à 12 ans précise si c'était voilà donc
ce nom est locale je sais qu'arnaud
m'avait indiqué il ya une joueuse qui
était parti de chez nous qui est allé
jusqu'à l'équipe de france jeunes c'est
clémence campagne ben s'il avait su il
aurait bien aimé la récupérer quoi et
voilà on doit après ce sont des
problèmes de ou deux par an ou deux le
président mais c'est le rôle d'un
président d'orienter les joueurs à
profil vous étiez président de montigny
ce que à l'époque vous aviez crise et
des passerelles entre amis avant et ce
sont les parents qui ont décidé c'est à
dire ils ont décidé d'aller sur un autre
club je savais que c'était pas très
pratique pour la jeune fille et puis
c'est quand même parce qu'il ya un lien
qu'il ya quelque part un peu plus facile
de faire montigny ici et willow que de
faire ici
cergy enfin montigny cergy quoi voilà
donc pour moi il ya des erreurs à ne pas
faire
litoria si vous faites un petit peu la
promotion du paris 92 à mon team retenue
non non pas du tout numérique et les
personnes changent et les responsables
change
la majorité de mes entraîneurs je vais à
mon pti ne sont plus du tout et on a
strasbourg et d'un peu partout hainard
bretagne et les joueuses maintenant je
vous reconnais 3,4 dans l'équipe
actuelle c'est donc j'ai pu beaucoup de
liens avec les personnes actuelle
d'accord ce suivi pour compléter à
montigny donc on a des jeunes filles qui
sont partis il y en a deux qui joue en
d2 à vaulx en velin et puis
au civil la octeville
voilà donc en fait c'est plaisant de
voir que les jeunes filles qui
réussissent eux n'a plus y avait plus vu
un dijon le 10 juin qui est quant à lui
très justement les passerelles patrick
chabot à l'arrivée de la passerelle à
passer c'est sûrement parce qu'ils en
avaient parlé avec le président de
montigny christophe reding oui oui je
suis à discuter il est apparemment on a
un club référence et quand on a des
joueuses à profil même dans tous les cas
il est nécessaire d'avoir des liens avec
les clubs de haut niveau
parce qu'en fait
le club de haut niveau aa n'a pas
forcément connaissance de déjouer à
profil et donc c'est un instant des
liens un dialogue que l'on peut arriver
à et profiter de de l'expérience d'un
club de haut niveau c'est ça aussi qui
motive et qui permet de
d'avoir aussi quelque part des
supporters pour les choses alors de
bonnes qu'il y ait de plus en plus de
jouer divine oiseaux paris 92 il faut
obligatoirement un vivier important pour
alimenter les clubs dans les ennemis
nous avons exactement 42 clubs répartis
sur le territoire et près de 7000
licenciés
on va les dépasser d'ici la fin de
l'année l'un des meilleurs club local
reste montigny le bretonneux son équipe
senior féminine évolue donc en nationale
2 la question sur ce thème les i mean
sont elles une terre de handball où
était oui ou non à votre avis mais senna
je ne vous l'avais pas de tous les
éléments en main bras sur vous pouvez
voter également partie on fait un petit
duel entre vous étiez vert à la base un
petit duel entre victoria et à chloé
victoria pourquoi plus gros ajustement
est l'occasion de jouer au vélodrome moi
personnellement par contre j'ai eu
l'occasion de voir coéquipières y jouer
et c'était je pense une des rares fois
où on a rempli autant un gymnase avec
autant de place donc cinq mille 5000
places s'était empli c'est quand même un
beau score c'est vrai que c'est plus
compliqué de remplir des gymnases plus
proche de région parisienne donc je
pense qu'il ya un vrai intérêt en tout
cas pour le handball c'est sûr vous le
ressentez oui ce que vous répondez à à
victoria je suis d'accord mais y'a
jamais autant comme fait pour un match
que pour le
vélodrome donc si on a là comme si on a
la même comme à tous les matchs on
remplit aussi notre pds voilà on n'a pas
de chiffres pas trop ça après si on fait
un match je ne sais pas dans le val de
marne peut-être que ce sera aussi rempli
couper l'eau drôme 20 on peut pas
trouver sa voie parce que terre de
lamballe ça veut dire
alors oui ça ça veut pas dire forcément
supporters bon match non perdon vater
dirt bike and run tour et dit d'accord
patrick chabot oui car bien que là c'est
parfaitement les arrange pour s'étirer
jusqu'à dire le contraire les noms c'est
normal c'est une terre de handball en
termes d'effectifs oui parce que près de
huit mille licenciés 7 milles 7 me
laisser monter jusqu'à d'immigrés s'est
montré discret des prés de lui qu'il
donc c'est l'un des comités les plus
importants avec la seine-et-marne et
puis le 91 l'essonne en termes de
qualité je dirais non parce que il ya
très peu de clubs représentés en jeu
mais la france donc chez les garçons il
y en a deux le ch est née puis plaisir
gelly relativement aimons conflent et
coffre et montigny donc et ce n'est
qu'un niveau intermédiaire de
championnat de france donc pour le
nombre de licenciés je trouve que c'est
pas suffisant donc 7000 licenciés en
france est plus de 500 milles 10 ans
hier le handball en jeu précise il y à
2373 club
oui du coup en france alors que quelques
dans les yvelines c'est un peu moins de
100 alors
on a augmenté le nombre de clubs ce
n'est pas en arrive à 42 ou 43 je crois
donc c'est bien mais je pense que ça car
on a un problème de qualité
seillier différentes choses des moyens
financiers peut être aussi l'année
qualité de l'encadrement et c'est
compliqué alors que d'autres
départements sont bien mieux situé
justement dans les autres départements
il ya notamment l'est de la france et le
nord de la france pourquoi a cloué à
votre avis longue balle pro mieux que
dans les yvelines
et si vous faisiez du sud est remercié
je sais qu'en bretagne en bretagne
également se montrer très grosse ligue
bah j'ai pas dans l'est de la france ya
pas grand chose à faire
vous appelez à paris ou comme habitat
mais ce jour préfère me sortir plus beau
jour de sa vie il n'y a pas que julien
dray mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il ya tellement de choses
culturellement ici dans l'île de france
que j'ai beaucoup d'offres qui a
beaucoup d'offres voilà donc dans la
tête du mal à se démarquer peut-être
aussi dans les yvelines
il ya nombreuses parents vous disiez
hyacinthe rigole notamment au citoyen d
un département il ya pile de golf mais
football c'est vrai que le handball
était déjà implanté mais pour rejoindre
la question précédente le nord mais il
ya quand même près de 50% de joueuses
féminines sur tout l'effectif donc c'est
un gros pôle féminin l'est parce que
c'est une culture ancestrale donc
ç'a toujours été et puis bon après sur
marseille je sais pas trop mais c'est
beau à marseille ensuite y'a rien n'y a
pas de club il ya quelques initiatives
qui sont menées dans les yvelines
justement pour faire grandir leur bal
féminin dans le département un club de
handball 100% féminin s'est créé il y a
deux saisons nous avions rencontré
fondatrice du club à l'époque signé
rodez guez et c'est au 7 avril preuve
pas donc c'est exclusivement des filles
on est sur une équipe plus 16 ans donc
il faut avoir minimum de 16 ans pour
s'inscrire et il n'y a pas de ya pas de
limite d'âge particulière donc on est
sur une équipe où il va y avoir des
compétitions on va rencontrer d'autres
équipes tout au long de l'année et et
puis voilà le seul mot je pense c'est la
motivation
patrick chabot qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette initiative m c'est très bien
d'avoir c'est un club qui vient de se
créer des deux saisons oui c'est ça donc
c'est tout récent c'est très bien il ya
un gros potentiel sur ce bassin de
plaisir les clés villepreux donc
vous avez changé peut-être avec sinon
retail est plutôt non non je la connais
pas du tout mais je connais la
présidente des claies n'est pas sale de
livres
qu'est-ce que vous conseillez du coup
pour que le club grandisse encore plus
et bien c'est s'appuyer sur l'expérience
des autres clubs surtout parce que pour
éviter que le nouveau président qui
arrive sans douter de la compétence de
la nouvelle présidente puisse s'appuyer
pour éviter de nouveaux ce que j'appelle
à redécouvrir le fil à couper le beurre
donc ça sert à rien donc
et ça c'est peut-être plus difficile
parce que c'est on n'ose pas où c'est
comme ça mais c'est le conseil que je
lui donnerai que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de cette initiative
c'est au club sur tours sont féminins
ouais c'est cool bah ouais j'suis ça
cool c'est bien pour ça a aidé à
développer peut-être un petit peu lors
d'un séminaire sur les épines comme
celui faut demander aux parisiennes moi
je peux la seule pas parisienne ces
questions c'est pas pour moi en libye
alors je pensais avoir peut-être une
peut-être une explication il se trouve
que aux alentours il ya des clubs qui
sont plutôt pro masculin donc de ce fait
il ya des jeunes filles qui arriva
ne pas s'exprimer je sais qu'il ya un
gros vivier sur l'île pour eux il ya
notamment un enseignant qui est très
bord du parlement de bâle il y à 1132
famille censier dans les yvelines sur
7000 licenciés
alice c'est trop peu c'est pas beaucoup
et bah du coup les des initiatives comme
ça ça permet d'augmenter vachement le
nombre de licenciées féminines donc ça
fait que du plus pour le handball
féminin on va ouvrir maintenant notre
page coup de projecteur dans notre coup
de projecteur nous allons parler du
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la structure a déjà été utilisée à deux
fois par accueillir des matches du paris
92 à l'époque le nom de l'équipe était
ici paris handball la première
collaboration date de 2017
il ya eu un match de championnat et un
match de coupe d'europe on écoute les
réactions des joueurs à la fin de ces
matches fantastiques magnifiques gros
merci
c'est que ça et
ils ont nous aider beaucoup franchement
une grosse salle bonne ambiance et je
pense que c'est grâce à saint-quentin
qu'aujourd'hui on a réussi et
franchement on avait à coeur de bien
faire ici sur sur le stade vélodrome est
montré qu' on a des très belles salles à
paris bon ce sont des bons souvenirs non
victoria pour vous hésitez pas laitiers
pain fait comment vous avez vibré du
coup pour cette partie c'est particulier
vélodrome parce que y'a le terrain et un
la piste de vélo tour et après il ya les
spectateurs ça met une certaine distance
en même temps ça fait que plus
spectaculaire
enfin - du convient d'en haut c'est
vraiment spectaculaire ça fait vraiment
et c'est ces grands malibu moi j'y étais
j'ai fait que au match de coupe d'europe
les images on a vu j étais pas mais du
coup pour avoir jouer sur ce terrain
c'est vrai que comme c'est victoria but
de des tribunes ça fait grand mais vu du
terrain ça fait très très grands aussi
c'est assez impressionnant
alors vous chloé alors c'est pas le
stade vélodrome de marseille en c1 c'est
le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qu'est ce que
vous en avez pensé alors du coup bah oui
c'est gigantesque
et puis du monde y avait une super
ambiance était à moi pareil j'étais là
que pour le match de coupe d'europe on a
perdu
du coup jean capin
un souvenir génial c'est qu'on a perdu
20 d'un muscle que d'un but donc défaite
amère mais
mais par contre oui par contre le public
était au rendez vous le vélodrome est
juste magnifique donc c'était top de
bras oh moi je n'ai vécu les deux années
la première c'était ailleurs que la
france de la meilleure il y avait la
victoire au bout
mais oui c'est vrai que c'est
impressionnant parce que déjà c'est une
grande salle même s'il ya la piste de
city seul au milieu ça paraît vraiment
grand et puis ai beaucoup d'ambiance
avait beaucoup de bruit enfin il ya être
plein d'animations et franchement c'est
bien pour 2 1 le sport féminin
et puis de 2 pour le club et puis pour
les yvelines aussie qui pouvait voir un
match de hand chômage justement c'est
incroyable comment
on s'est créé ce partenariat finalement
comment il s'écrie c'est vous qui êtes
allé chercher paris 92 vous et allez
vous chercher n'ont ni l'un ni l'autre
c'est en fait j'avais cette idée là déjà
avant la construction du vélodrome
j'ai eu six lits comme j'ai vu projet
lillois faire du handball là dedans et
en fait j'ai fait visiter cette enceinte
à de nombreuses personnes se soient des
entraîneurs de l'équipe de france et
notamment arnaud gandais le manager via
un trailer et puis arnaud vous êtes
capable de faire quelque chose là dedans
et c'est comme ça que c'est parti donc
c'est un mille quatre ans pour être
concrétisées bon c'était du travail
totalement et on découvrait tout mais
c'est pas c'est pas une salle qui est
conçu pour ça donc il a fallu vraiment
travaillé sur les difficultés justement
de il faut tout installé par exemple
vous avez à l'intérieur de leurs
centrales
c'est juste du béton qui est très propre
mais il n'y a pas de parquet n'y a rien
donc il faut tout mettre au niveau
logistique c'est compliqué c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué je vais aider à
installer les eaux là le terrain il ya
eu le travail préparatoire en amont mais
il ya eu 6 après le les jours qui ont
précédé le match il fallait tout
installer l'équipe de florennes à
l'époque avec les bénévoles de 10,6 par
et puis les bénévoles du secteur
donc c'est vrai que c'était un gros
travail et puis en même temps on a
réussi à mutualiser aussi d
avec l'aide de la de la ville de
montigny qui a était allé chercher le
matériel est ici ou hinault donc non non
c'était très bien et puis avec eux oui
puis un gros travail de communication
sur sur le 51è si on en parlait
justement tu es pressé d'avant la
question sur ce thème le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines peut-il
devenir le terrain officiel du paris 92
voter oui ou non
alice regarde clos est bon pour
s'inspirer de mettre autre chose que
alice pourquoi alors alors tour l'a dit
notre look les tables on va être
d'accord moi pourquoi non parce que déjà
on n'est pas dans le 92 notre ne
s'apprête pas à 92 déjà c'est pas loin
oui mais l'île de france il ya tout qui
est pas loin on pourrait jouer dans tout
l'est dans tous les départements et est
aussi c'est pas c'est une salle qui est
bien pour apple pour un événement dans
l'année mais
et one shot pour voilà pour pour y jouer
toute l'année je suis pas sûr que ce
soit le top
ja comme disait patrick patrick niveau
logistique
ça demande énormément de travail et donc
si on va faire ça tous les week-ends
après c'est possible je suis pas sûr je
serai trop d'argent va ça coûterait
beaucoup trop d'argent beaucoup trop de
temps enfin les bénévoles ils sont
adorables mais ils ont pas faire ça tous
les week-ends
c'est compliqué et puis aussi mais voilà
comme elle disait c'est pas le 92 elle
s'est passée ta insider voilà justement
ce qui est un problème d'identité a
finalement deborah peut-être d'identité
identité par rapport 78,92 parce que les
supporters pourraient se sentir un petit
peu mal à l'aise par rapport à cette
situation s'il devait y avoir une
délocalisation à peut-être mais surtout
bas tous les actionnaires du club
enfin on est basée à issy de mondino
donc on comprendrait pas pourquoi on
ferait à 50 ans indivisible on devine
pardon puis bah oui c'est pas la ville
c'est pas la ville dans laquelle nos
joueuses pas l'habitude club donc un
événement comme ça d'accord mais tout le
temps je pense pas victoria alors vous
vous habitez le coin on dit depuis le
début de l'émission et vous voter quand
même lot voilà c'est pour les mêmes
raisons ce qui est important c'est de
jouer à la maison est voir vos amis pour
moi c'est super mais c'est pas loin on
qui peuvent se déplacer aussi ce qui est
important c'est de jouer à la maison
donc si on n'est même pas à la maison à
la maison c'est compliqué le fil 78 20
millions d'euros
cette égalisation patrick je dirais pour
des raisons je connais lui l'utilisation
du vélodrome
c'est un peu comme la robert charpentier
à issy les moulineaux lorsqu'il ya des
événements vous êtes obligé de jouer à
l'extérieur ailleurs et bien le
vélodrome c'est la même chose donc
dedans il peut y avoir des événements
qui font que ce soit pas possible et en
plus comme le vélodrome n'est pas du
tout équipés de façon durable aux
versions handball je vois pas tout
déménager d'un jour à l'autre
il faut la salle présente à l'empt la
salle disponible aux entraînements aux
matches c'est c'est inconcevable dans
l'état actuel il ya quand même quatre
mille personnes qu'on peut mettre en
plus quand même dans le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plutôt que
dans le du coup le stade de discipline
ou lors le stade le gymnase par grand
pardon
robert charpentier oui tout à fait et
puis je suis d'accord avec alice en
disant que pour d un poème
d'événementiel c'est très bien pourquoi
parce que lorsque dernièrement on a eu
en a vendu 1000 billets pour des
licenciés sur le match de coupe d'europe
il ya eu quand même 4715 entrez donc les
premiers sets sans ils viennent d'où ils
viennent des gens qui sont non licenciés
et ça c'est très important sur le plan
de la promotion
ça veut dire qu'on est capable de
motiver des gens pour voir un événement
de ce genre est ce que ça peut être un
plus aussi au niveau de l'ambiance aussi
des résultats du coup chloé est ce que
ça peut mettre la pression aussi sur sur
les adversaires de savoir d'avoir
d'abord 7000 personnes autour bien sûr
qui vous supportent bas on sait très
bien je pense que personne ne va me
contredire d'avoir d'avoir un public ça
fait ça peut faire la différence dans un
match d'avoir un public qui qui qui
pousse l'équipe voilà qui nous encourage
ça peut vraiment faire la différence
d'où l'importance de
des matches à domicile bas est ce qu'il
ya un autre match qui sera programmé au
mieux les tombes de saint quentin en
yvelines on sait par ac
d'abord ça va mais pense que c est dans
les cartons ben pour moi c'est un vrai
carton je suis pas tout ça c'est pas je
ne suis pas le décideur
je sais que les élus et puis beaucoup de
gens qui ont vécu déjà ses deux premiers
événements attendent un troisième
événement
jamais deux sans trois vous voulez la
nouvelle événements autour de cette
table à l'historien vaudois domicile une
fois les bras même chose pour vous mais
pas contre non mais c'est pas tout le
temps c'est que pour moi j'aime moi
personnellement j'ai pas envie de jouer
à saint quentin en yvelines quand c'est
un match décisif commencer un match
vraiment important pour nous parce que
on est nous haïssent ils à robert entier
dans notre dans notre bulle c'est chez
nous c'est notre maison en habitué à
jouer là on habitue à tirer là donc ça
on connaît la maison vraiment et ça ça
joue tellement que pour un événement
comme ça je pense que pour un match
vital c'est pas bon ça sera le mot de la
fin sur cette thématique les corps et on
passe maintenant l'autre dernière page
la rubrique débats
[Musique]
dans cette fange débat nous allons
parler de la médiatisation du handball
féminin dans l'hexagone un coup de
projecteur sera mis sur les 1 féminine
dans les prochaines semaines la 13e
édition du championnat d'europe féminin
seront organisées pour la toute première
fois de son histoire en france du 29
novembre au 16 décembre
il y aura des matches à nantes à brest à
montbéliard a - nancy et à paris mais le
handball féminin reste moins médiatique
que le handball masculin il faut le dire
qui a pu compter sur les très bons
résultats de l'équipe de france pour se
faire une place face au football ou
encore au rugby la question sur ce thème
le handball féminin sera-t-il un jour
plus fort que le handball masculin
vous votez oui ou non non non non ah oui
un petit duel entre alice et chloé petit
débat yvo débat il faut débattre
activement sa présence à l'iss c'est à
vous je pense que non parce que
on est toujours bas on y suit en fait on
est toujours par rapport au handball
masculin toujours là comme ça ça voulait
dire on va dire qu'on a un petit ballon
de retard patronat et du coup déjà
vis-à-vis des résultats des équipes de
france
même si les filles voilà ont remporté
l'année dernière une compétition mais
les garçons c'est vrai que ça fait pas
mal d'années qui sont qui sont loin
devant les filles et je pense que ça
aussi ça fait beaucoup et
voilà oui chloé c'est à vous alors moi
je suis un peu féministe et pour le coup
je suis d'accord sur le fait que les
garçons ils ont tous gagné donc c'est
deux médailles d'or aux jo six fois
champion du monde trois championnats
d'europe pour les filles ces deux
championnats du monde dont 1 du coup en
2010 est en vous disiez précédemment et
une médaille d'argent aux jo donc la
petite différence au niveau du palmarès
mais bien sûr c'est pour ça que la cc
force et c'est légitime qui soit
beaucoup plus médiatisé voilà il le
mérite c'est normal d'après l'équipe de
france féminine commence à faire se
faire une place au niveau mondial
voilà on commence à être être télévisé
commence à me a parlé du handball
féminin donc bah moi j'y crois pourquoi
pas après je souhaite pas de mal à
l'équipe de france masculine
parce que pour qu'on passe devant
falloir qu'ils perdent un peu et qui ont
gagné un peu plus mais pourquoi pas en
tout cas j'espère j'espère qu'un jour ce
sera là au même niveau de bord qui vous
a convaincu un peu des deux en vrai les
gars au ils sont plus médiatisée parce
qu'ils ont fait de bons résultats et ces
résultats ils ont perduré dans le temps
alors que les filles bas on commence
tout juste si ça perdure peut-être qu'on
deviendra aussi médiatisé que le garçon
donc à voir dans quelques années après
il ya un phénomène sociétal aux siens
enfin clairement
les femmes n'ont jamais été plus
médiatisés qui les hommes en france sont
des gens en france aient déjà rêvé par
exemple en tennis c'est déjà arrivé au
ps oui mais ça dans une course comme ça
maintenant on fait un sport masculin en
plus il est là tu as you oui enfin
j'imagine que dans la danse classique la
femme est plus mises à l'honneur
nous on fait déjà un sport masculin donc
donc c'est un peu plus compliqué de
passer devant les garçons mais en plus
ce n'est pas un sport national par
exemple je sais que en hongrie jouer à
angry mois le handball c'est sport
national et les filles des hommes ils
sont au même niveau
en roumanie c'est les femmes qui sont
devant les hommes parce qu'elles sont
meilleures
donc je suis en norvège ne parlons même
pas ben quoi que les hommes commencent à
revenir oui mais voilà en fait il suffit
juste qu'on soit forte
les mecs soient nuls et peut-être contre
hanovre
patricia ben oui va je vais chance et
l'a été dit mais je trouve que le
handball féminin d'abord a
considérablement évolué il ya des 35 %
de filles sur les 500 me licencier pôle
i-trans et 500 à l'échelon national et
je trouve le handball féminin est plus
agréable à regarder plus technique et
s'était alors que le handball c'est du
un contre un c'est très physique
c'est sincèrement c'est plus agréable à
regarder du handball féminin de haut
niveau qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
peut-être pour augmenter cette notoriété
précédemment clou et se sont forcément
les résultats de l'équipe nationale qui
vont influer sur la hausse ou pas des
licenciés au niveau féminin
nuno rythme a dit du coup je veux non
oui mais voilà les réseaux les grands
résultats ski médiatisé donc l'équipe
aux gagnants enveloppe faut gagner ce
championnat d'europe faut qu'une équipe
française s'illustre au moins sur le
podium vous
la chaîne publique il faut faire des
podiums important donc on y apprend doit
performer en coupe d'europe
paris 80 2 way fait son bout de chemin
on verra ce que ça donne à l'équipe
nationale c'est quand même la vitrine du
vin c'est ce qui représente ou
l'invasion forcément l'équipe nationale
à des résultats ça pousse derrière les
garçons quand ils ont gagné
je reviens du monde et c'est vrai il ya
eu
monter des bénévoles importe quoi ils
licenciés derrière
sachant que le plus difficile est bon
bah c'est d'un 17 jours à la maison
est-ce qu'ils vont pas peut-être une
tête d'affiche quand même au handball
film dans une tête d'affiché comme
karabatic par exemple un acquis et futur
ballon d'or
qu'est ce que vous en pensez quoi
une tête d'affiché affiche peut-être un
peu plus médiatisés comme karabatic est
actuellement fabriqué par la fédération
ouais c'est clair il est connu si on
parle à quelqu'un dans la rue de
handball il veut dire 40 au titre même
si connais pas du tout loin de base donc
c'est ça va un peu au-delà du en valeur
et tout ça c'est vrai dit sportif du
sportif c'est une icône humaine donc oui
nous on a pas moyen n'a pas une image
comme ça d'un bal féminin il n'en manque
pas justement des têtes d'affiché
patrick szewe dans la vie il ya nikola
karabatic a été je crois deux fois sur
meilleur joueur du monde il est utile et
variées aussi puis chez les filles il ya
eu comment s'appelle allison pineau
voilà dix ans oui c'est ça donc moi
c'est différent c'est que les
et les joueurs de l'équipe de france les
garçons ils sont ils ont tous gagné la
ligue des champions et j'ai surtout joué
dans les meilleurs clubs du monde
voilà nom n'a pas trop ça finalement
tant dans nos équipes de france à nous
non pas de superstar
dernière question est ce que les matchs
seront enfin les matchs seront diffusés
sur robin sport et certains matches de
la france sur tf6 ou tf1 le groupe tf1
est ce qui la visibilité du coup sûr cet
événement victoria peut apporter au
handball féminin bien sûr qu'il faut que
tous les matchs se sont en prime time
sur tf1
moi j'adorais ça serait génial de paille
chercher sur internet pour trouver les
matches mais non ça serait génial
d'avoir le maximum de matches et ça fait
plaisir
puis tous les amateurs de hand forcément
lui mais leur télé et regardez donc ça
fait que parler un peu plus et ceux qui
ne regarde jamais les endives aux appels
vont tomber dessus peut-être que ça mais
les faire rester donc forcément c'est
peut-être une nouvelle tête qu'on qu'on
va donc c'est important plus de
supporters je suppose
alors nous allons refermer ce magazine
par un quiz le principe est simple je
vais poser des questions et vous l
inscrire le nom d'une des joueuses
autour de cette table sur cette ardoise
a qu'une petite ardoise chloé montrer la
petite ardoise pour que les
téléspectateurs puissent comprendre
voilà patrick chaboud alors peut-être
excluant de ce genre voilà ce sujet que
les joueuses qui vont jouer alors vous
mais vous pouvez quand même réagir
patrick arnoux alors première question
qu'on se fie mais le plus d'ambiance
dans le vestiaire
aucune ombre et man 2 4 avec les clients
il faut pas répondre en tiff vous pouvez
réagir simuler patrick rapidement bien
sûr
c'est dur c'est pas une interrogation
mais c'est dur à l'écart n'était pas eu
un deborah chloé et miquelon et sa
défense est partagé entre eux des liens
aussi hasardeuse au bonhomme est un
levier direction vous pouvez effacer
vous pouvez fasse et maintenant ils
pouvaient toujours réagir deuxième
question qui est la plus chambreuse
victoria ces caissons rapidité aussi
patronne ans et vous êtes à domicile
mais parfois trop vous êtes l'appui
chambreuse 2 à l'asie cloud et on va
crever je pensais que vous avez été élu
alors 3r question qui est la plus
mauvaise perdante savez patrick petite
idée on prenait pas du tout venant mais
s'ils disent oui répondent pour vous
mais moi aussi je précise 3le à alice
plus deborah alice alice bon alice
apparemment c'est un plébiscite en tongs
ou surtout aux jeux d'échauffement
[Musique]
et la dernière à rester à l'entraînement
la dernière à rester la plus travaillée
[Musique]
voter c'est bon vingt trois deux un
joker ces personnes notre d'accord
jocaste reine quitte alors avant
dernière question qui la joueuse
préférée du coach pour vous clowe vous
êtes à capitaine 3 2 1
je n'ai pas envie d'aller c'est pas lui
qui m'a élu capitaine moi je possède pas
j'avais d'ailleurs question qui est la
première à faire la fête après les
matches
toujours là toujours la dame apparemment
l'impression que par bribes is it une
nouvelle fois 3 2 1
bah c'est des fois ce jeune ça c'est aux
jeunes elles sortent jamais assez
sérieusement jamais elle ne voit jamais
une goutte d'alcool est scotché
génération bien sûr avec modération fait
toujours toujours c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouve le 5 décembre
prochain pour une nouvelle émission va
terminer par une citation de la légende
du handball français thierry omeyer
il faudra me tuer pour me sortir de
l'équipe je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phase
à bientôt sur des veillées 78
[Musique]